[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's gonna be that kind of
move hanging out to the spotlight
blowing holes in the dark
took forever
[Music]
clouds rolling over sunlight
it's no fun for the young
[Music]
can they just steadily see someone
anyone thought out from the frostbite
[Music]
such peace for the eyes
[Music]
may i have this dance before we dry
you want to swim with the alligator yeah
yeah yeah yeah
take a seat near the imitator yeah yeah
yeah yeah
instead a year or a minute later yeah
yeah yeah yeah
we're so much better when we're scared
together
[Music]
enough of a highlight
[Music]
that i eating had my mind
it was a beautiful design
redesign take home the rewind
fast forward to the end
[Music]
when done you begun to begin again
free falling
[Music]
yeah so much better when we're scared
together
[Music]
so much better when we're scared
together
[Music]
this breathing room we've made it better
i changed so soon we made so much better
a day
[Music]
this breathing room we made it better it
changed so soon we made so much better
[Music]
[Music]
yeah yeah
[Music]
we're so much better when we're scared
together
[Music]